ascolto spesso raccontare delle storie
ognuno ha i suoi personaggi suoi luoghi
ognuna porta dentro e dietro di sé altre
storie che spesso non vengono raccontate
all'interno di ogni storia ci sono
drammi speranze interessi contrasti e
con interessi e contrasti le storie
cercano di tuffarsi nel mare del diritto
per trovare il loro diciamo così il loro
alloggiamento la loro dimensione più
sicura più protetta
spesso capita che le storie abbiano dei
denominatori comuni ma questo è un forse
un vizio del mio lavoro eppure ognuna
conserva una sua originalità perché
dentro di sé alla
l'emozione
l'irrazionalità la cultura di chi le
vive e le racconta è un grande
privilegio poterli ascoltare
perché un momento di crescita un momento
di importante comprensione del mondo e
del tempo che viviamo e soprattutto
della difficoltà dei rapporti umani
e poi le storie possono essere
raccontate anche da altri punti di vista
e possono avere far scoprire dei luoghi
degli interessi diversi
quando le storie cercano di tuffarsi nel
mondo del diritto
c'è bisogno di informazione c'è bisogno
di consapevolezza informata quel quel
quid che ti fa dire alla fine sono
soddisfatto ho raggiunto i miei
obiettivi
non si tratta di saper scegliere o di
saper decidere si tratta di sapere per
decidere o di sapere per scegliere
all'inizio dell'ottocento
jeremy bentham diceva che il fine ultimo
del diritto come del resto della vita e
la ricerca della felicità ma questo vale
per tanti livelli stati comunità
organizzate famiglie può sembrare
persino più semplice quando si tratta di
trovare un accordo tra due persone
quando si tratta di conciliare i loro
bisogni alla ricerca delle figlie eppure
qualche cosa si trattasse
marco e tani ad esempio volevano
aggiungere un bel segmento al loro
percorso di vita
lui 35 anni un lavoro da poco diventato
definitivo
contratto a tempo determinato gran cosa
di questi tempi la sua famiglia
d'origine lontana
tania deal anni più grande di lui e con
un lavoro da segretaria amministrativa
in una piccola azienda un figlio di 4
anni è una bimba che stava arrivando
per loro era arrivato il momento di
cambiare casa di trovare una casa più
grande e soprattutto più comoda e più
vicini ai genitori di lei perché agli
inizi una mano nella gestione del menage
familiare importante poi lo sappiamo con
i figli uno più uno non fai mai 2
in realtà
quello
che loro volevano era finalmente una
casa di proprietà
una casa di proprietà e un passaggio
importante nella vita di tanti una sorta
di punto di arrivo e di ripartenza
in fondo nonostante le nostre vite siano
così accelerate così rapsodiche la casa
rappresenta un'ancora di certezze quel
quel luogo sicuro e far ritorno dove ci
si sente circondati delle cose che si
amano che si è fatte proprie ma
soprattutto la casa e
quell'intimo palcoscenico dove poter
recitare finalmente la propria parte
senza sentirsi giudicati da occhi
indiscreti
la casa è un passo importante e per
questo perché comporta sacrifici che la
si vuole perfetta in fondo quando si
parla di casa è un qualcosa che ti senti
addosso come come un cappotto come come
una camicia come una tasca piena ma qui
forse c'è una canzone che mi sta
distraendo e vi giuro che non da canto
marco e tania però la casa la volevano
pronta non c'era tempo per ristrutturare
volevano sistemare la loro situazione
prima che arrivasse la bimba
è in questo percorso erano anche
agevolati dal fatto che potevano
approfittare di un mutuo che avrebbe
comodamente trasformato una rata di
canone mensile in una rata di mutuo
arresto per quel che mancava per pagare
la casa ci avrebbero pensato i genitori
di lei sì i genitori in fondo è l'ultima
generazione a cui è stato consentito di
mettere qualcosa da parte di risparmiare
secondo il noto principio che non si sa
mai
e qui le storie dentro le storie
cominciavano a cavallar se
la casa praticamente l'avevano già
trovata
in una zona comoda su due piani con un
bel giardino che girava per due lati
l'edificio non era
recentissimo però il proprietario
l'aveva completamente ristrutturato da
dieci anni
e poi dall'altra parte della strada a
300 metri cioè del condominio dei
genitori quindi avevano valutato tutto
praticamente tutto o quasi
la storia di eugenia completamente
diversa
50 anni fisioterapista
un divorzio alle spalle chiusa da
quattro anni due figli universitari a
suo carico lui voleva chiudere un
percorso della sua vita aveva già deciso
dove trasferirsi per una nuova casa ma
prima di prendere impegni voleva esser
sicuro di poter vendere bene quella che
aveva
in fondo aveva chiesto anche all'agente
immobiliare che gli aveva rassicurato
che lo aveva rassicurato dicendogli
guarda la casa vale esattamente quello
che pensi quindi c'è anche la
possibilità di trovare delle buone
offerte ma soprattutto tempestive anche
lui aveva valutato praticamente tutto
le loro storie fino a un momento prima
totalmente sconosciute l'una all'altra
si erano incontrati
e ora c'era la necessità di farle
parlare di far dialogare i loro bisogni
di cercare che i loro bisogni
riuscissero a seguire il percorso della
felicità
e c'era bisogno di fare delle domande
proprio sulla casa vale a dire ciò che
era l'oggetto di scambio e di
aspettative
a marco e tania per esempio piaceva il
fatto che la casa fosse su due piani in
fondo al piano di sopra c'era una bella
cameretta con un bagno è un domani
quando i ragazzini diventavano grandi si
poteva pensare di avere camerette
separate quindi una gran comodità
eppure sul progetto
quella che doveva essere una camera con
bagno era in realtà una soffitta con un
lavatoio
eugenio ci aveva speso dei soldi in
fondo quella quella casa lui l'aveva
trovata così come la vedevamo
aveva messo il parquet al piano di sopra
aveva sostituito i sanitari era tutto lì
ben chiaro evidente
nessuno sarà contestare questo ma quella
che doveva essere una stanza con bagno
era in realtà una soffitta con un
lavatoio e qui il il diritto cominciava
a innalzare i suoi steccati regolatori
la casa era esattamente quella che
volevano marchetta a casa valeva
esattamente quando per quanto pensava il
genio eppure
è un po come quando hai una camicia che
ti che acqua che cucitura che ti crea
allergie
alla fine la darei via peccato che era
piaciuta ti piaceva ma se avessi letto
bene l'etichetta forse poteva immaginare
che c'era qualcosa che poteva darti noia
anche la casa piaceva era piaciuta è
però non sarebbe stata la stessa cosa
poterla dare via così velocemente
c'era la necessità però di fare qualche
altra domanda allora ho anticipato le
loro domande
ma c'erano tutti i documenti da
consegnare agli acquirenti
in fondo la risposta sembrava scontata
eugenio aveva ristrutturato la casa da
dieci anni e poi i documenti erano tutti
lì sul tavolo
nessun problema
ma gli impianti
lui aveva rifatti tutti però gli aveva
fatto in economia che è quella locuzione
che vuol dire tanto e poco spesso
grazie ad amici conoscenti aveva anche
speso dei soldi ma tutti gli impianti
erano totalmente privi di certificati
il tuffo nel mare del diritto da parte
di eugenio si era fatto pericoloso
e soprattutto non aveva
con sé quel po di consapevolezza
informata che era necessario
in fondo quando si ha qualcosa di
importante bisogna avere cura ed
attenzione
che ne so se hai una macchina d'epoca
farai di tutto per
dotarla i pezzi di ricambio originali
continuerà a mantenere il suo valore e
potrà dimostrarlo
eugenio questo lo aveva trascurato tutto
nuovo soldi spesi ma quel valore non era
certificabile
le loro storie che erano corse l'uno
incontro all'altra fino a quel momento
si erano improvvisamente arrestate quel
senso di benessere che portava la
realizzazione dei loro bisogni era
fermo le storie erano origine l'una di
fronte all'altra
e nel momento
in cui
cercavano
di dialogare nascevano dei contrasti non
c'erano i presupposti
per immaginare che marco e tani avessero
fatto un azzardo non c'erano nemmeno i
presupposti per immaginare che un genio
fosse stato reticente
non c'era nemmeno di mezzo
armando feroci il celebre agente
immobiliare rappresentato da carlo
verdone c'era soltanto una scarsa
consapevolezza
troppo spesso ci si preoccupa di rischi
molto eclatanti ma poco probabili
e ci si tutela dei mentre si tralasciano
dei rischi che sono magari più probabili
ma che sembrano forse più abbordabili
la differenza è che di questi ultimi non
si ha consapevolezza non se ne parla
eppure questi rischi sono in grado di
creare
ulteriori disagi le domande adesso le
facevano loro ed erano diventate
incalzanti
ma allora senza
agibilità c'era rischio per la residenza
per marco e tania oppure a causa di
quella soffitta l'agibilità poteva
essere revocata
e
e se si poteva sistemare quella casa
con quanti soldi con quanto tempo
bisognava sentire un tecnico un
architetto chi saman
sembravano saltati tutti i presupposti e
poi per quella storia degli impianti beh
allora forse la casa non valeva più
esattamente tanto forse anche la banca
non avrebbe dato più il mutuo che loro
speravano
ciò che era un percorso di benessere si
era completamente arrestato
c'erano degli accordi in piedi però a
questo punto ognuno aveva di che
lamentare qualcosa i loro interessi
erano diventati dei contrasti
a questa storia noi possiamo scrivere
tanti finali un accordo saltato un
accordo drammaticamente finito in
tribunale un lunghissimo iter per
regolarizzare la soffitta gli impianti
un tira e molla sul prezzo a sconti
concessi o sconti richiesti
forse proprio per questo non importa
come sia finita
l'unica certezza è che senza quelle
informazioni iniziali senza quella
consapevolezza informata senza quella
cura che fa la differenza in un acquisto
certificato senza quell attenzione a
quell insieme di documenti che non sono
solo dei pezzi di carta ma che
rappresentano il valore intimo della
casa
nessuno è riuscito a dire sono
soddisfatto ho raggiunto il mio
obiettivo con quella naturalezza e
spontaneità che un passo così importante
meritava
il diritto aveva cercato di accompagnare
le loro storie alla ricerca della
felicità ma non gli hanno dato la
sufficiente importanza